>> The question today is: What one thing do
you think that
countries, companies, or individuals must
do to make the world a
better place in 2008?
>> Well, I think they should concentrate on
the neglected areas of
the world which, uh, do not get the attention
they should have ranging
from, let us say, Darfur, to, uh, the Horn
of Africa to, uh, points of
the subcontinent which are outside the mainstream,
the made trade
link -- the made trade link of information
of our policy because they
don't seem to be beneficial at this moment
but they have a way of
eventually imposing themselves on consciousness
through things that
happen that affect many people.
So therefore I think a sur -- a careful survey
to pick out -- the
hardest and most urgently which must be done
which are crucial and
obvious but that's the problem.
It's too hard and therefore the great exercise
we need to say what are
the most urgent and neglected places we should
help?
>> But don't you think mass media and wide
exposures is one step
actually to address the problem?
So we need to get the neglected issues out
into the mainstream?
>> Well, I think the mass media tends to follow
events rather than
lead them.
It's very unusual that they take the lead
and send people to places
that are so remote enough and not particularly
in the major focus and
the media tend to follow the great divine
and the public gesture of
the world leaders and the world leaders have
great power in that
sense.
>> Anything else that you would like to add?
>> No.
That's the thought -- one little thought for
[unintelligible]